[Musique]
bonjour le grand point virgule
c'est bien c'est bien parce que ça met
pas la pression d'avoir 300 personnes
quand tu viens juste d'écrire le dernier
mot de la dernière ligne d'un spectacle
que tu vas faire alors pour ceux qui
avaient pas vraiment compris le concept
c'est j'ai vraiment été enfermé durant
deux jours pour écrire un spectacle
voilà qui va durer 30-40 minutes c'est
pas mal un spectacle c'est 6 mois
d'écriture et six mois après de
répétition d'affinage de tests et après
ça part en tournée deux jours
de genre donc je sais pas tellement
est-ce que ça va donner c'est une
expérience que j'avais envie de vivre et
je suis content que vous soyez là aussi
pour la vivre avec moi je me suis dit le
premier truc déjà c'est peut-être de me
présenter parce qu'il y a peut-être des
gens qui ont emmené d'autres personnes
qui me connaissent pas je m'appelle
Fabian et je suis mentaliste voilà le
mentalisme c'est quoi démonstration quel
est ton prénom Aurore exactement
c'était un message tu vas adorer ce
spectacle car comme j'ai pas toujours eu
le temps de faire des grands numéros par
contre j'ai des petits numéros rapides
comme ça ça t'a bluffé toi ouais pas
tellement réponds pas réponse surtout
pas à ça donc le mentalisme c'est entre
entre la magie entre la voyance et
surtout une belle escroquerie quoi au
final on a bien compris mais c'est une
escroquerie qui dure depuis longtemps
parce que ça joue sur les schémas
cognitifs sur le fait d'illusionner le
cerveau des autres sur la psychologie et
moi je fais ça depuis très longtemps
maintenant je suis sur scène depuis des
années et des années depuis un peu plus
de 12 ans je viens de passer les 40 ans
tu vois ça se voit
non Fabien ça ne se voit pas
tu fais si jeune
et je suis en train de penser au futur
et je me dis demain il peut m'arriver un
truc peut m'arriver un truc et tout mon
savoir tous mes secrets tout ce que j'ai
pu monter cette chaîne Youtube tout ça
tous les spectacles tout ça il en reste
quoi il faut que je trouve un repreneur
et c'est ce que je me suis dit pendant
deux jours je me suis dit j'ai personne
qui vont venir c'est trouver parmi elles
qui est le meilleur ou la meilleure
mentaliste pour reprendre le job non
mais c'est vite fait tu vois je peux
marcher dans la rue et puis il y a un
bus qui passe des gens qui ont pas aimé
les analyses politiques que j'ai fait je
n'en sais rien tu vois un truc comme ça
ou un autre mentaliste chaud avec des
moustaches
on ne sait pas peut-être des gens me
veulent du mal tu vois je ne sais pas
donc je me dis je vais protéger mes
arrières et je vais trouver qui allait
compétences et la capacité le talent de
reprendre ce job là de mentaliste et je
lui donnerai les clés à la fin du
spectacle
c'est un peu une fin de carrière
que quand il m'arrivera quelque chose
c'est pas la peine de pousser dans les
escaliers à la fin de ce spectacle ok
soyons bien clair alors on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps devant nous donc on va
pas pouvoir couvrir tout ce qui compose
le mentalisme mais on va prendre deux
trois thèmes sur lequel je vais vous
faire des tests je vais vous demander de
répondre et de participer oralement à
ces spectacles pour vous le mentalisme
c'est quoi dites-moi
on ne sait toujours pas on est abonné
depuis 6 ans on ne sait pas Fabien c'est
quoi les thématiques que ça vous inspire
ça peut être la mémoire ça va être autre
chose tu vois
le mensonge oui non l'escroquerie on l'a
déjà dit l'analyse voilà ok le mensonge
l'analyse la mémoire tout ça ok on va
commencer par le mensonge c'est ce qui a
été prononcé en premier on va se faire
un rappel basique de tout ce qui compose
la détection de mensonges en partant du
principe que attention personne n'est
capable de détecter le mensonge à 100%.
mais on peut avoir des indices de
variation on fait un test collectif pour
vous rappeler les basiques après je vous
teste vous il me faudrait deux personnes
deux personnes qui veulent bien animer
ce petit test de mensonge et de vérité
avec moi lever la main les personnes qui
veulent participer oui tu as le pena en
première ton prénom Aurore enchanté
on a mis les Aurors au premier rang
c'est plus simple c'est pour moi tu vois
et toi ton prénom jeune homme
Aurore Baptiste venez sur scène s'il
vous plaît merci beaucoup
parfait salut Aurore mets-toi ici pour
le moment
Baptiste mets-toi là donc là pour
l'instant vous allez juste illustrer un
petit rappel de la détection de
mensonges pour une espèce de formation
rapide pour tous les futurs mentalistes
je vous demandais dans quelques secondes
de déterminer si vous allez mentir ou
dire la vérité vous allez choisir le
rôle que vous allez avoir pour répondre
aux questions donc vous choisissez soit
de mentir à chaque fois se dire la
vérité à chaque fois mais dans quelques
instants je vous demandais de vous
mettre au fond de la scène dans le
confessionnal vous allez vous tourner
secrètement et vous allez communiquer là
avec l'autre pour vous dire quel rôle
vous avez pris chacun vous pouvez
prendre de rôle identique c'est pas
gênant ils peuvent dire tous les deux la
vérité ou tous les deux mentir on ne le
sera pas ou avoir un rôle séparé pour
communiquer entre vous faites-le en mode
non verbal est-ce que vous maîtrisez la
télépathie
ok alors un mode non verbal facile quand
vous serez tourné vous dites à l'autre
un petit pouce en l'air si vous dites la
vérité et un petit pouce en bas si vous
mentez ce sera la manière de communiquer
entre vous si ce que je viens de dire
est clair je vais vous demander de
mettre le pouce comme ceci et de faire
c'est super
ressemblance merci beaucoup donc aller
derrière communiquer entre vous cachez
bien ce que vous vous faites il y a
juste l'un et l'autre doit savoir le
rôle de l'autre mais le public est
moi-même nous ne devons pas le savoir
donc vous pouvez vous mettre ici vous
dire ok moi je vais faire ça moi je vais
faire ça vous n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir
cette
pendant ce temps là on va mettre en
place notre manière de procéder quand il
reviendront je leur poserai deux
questions et on essaiera de déterminer
là c'est surtout moi qui vais bosser
encore une fois retenez ma manière de
faire parce qu'après ce sera à vous de
bosser c'est ce que je viens de dire et
bien clair vous mettez le pouce en l'air
et vous faites c'est super
on vous fait faire n'importe quoi c'est
ça l'influence principale
Baptiste Aurore est-ce que c'est bon
pour vous parfait retournez-vous s'il
vous plaît
Baptiste mets-toi sur ce plan point
blanc tu seras bien dans la lumière et
Aurore sur ce point blanc s'il te plaît
mettez-vous face au public à partir de
moments de ce moment-là vous êtes dans
mes angles morts de ne vous verrez pas
est-ce que vous voyez ce que je fais moi
avec mes mains Aurore et Baptiste non ça
va être ma manière de vous indiquer à
vous le public ce que je pense qu'ils
font cette main là symbolise rabatie si
je la mets comme ça c'est que je pense
qu'il dit la vérité si tu la baisse
c'est que je pense qu'il ment et
inversement c'est facile
suivez ok vous connaissez tous les deux
votre propre rôle n'en changez pas et
vous connaissez le rôle de l'autre ne
répondez pas à cette question mais
hurler non non je crois que j'ai pas
compris un truc si c'est pas le cas ça
va
je pose des questions à l'un ou l'une
d'entre vous répondez moi selon le rôle
que vous avez choisi c'est essentiel
première question je ferme les yeux
parce que il y en a il y a des gens qui
pensent que si je le vois du coin de
l'oeil je pourrais savoir s'il manque
aussi disent la vérité c'est le cas
donc je vais fermer les yeux je ferme
les yeux je force même pour les fermer
Baptiste réponds-moi selon le rôle que
tu as choisi donc c'est à dire que si tu
mens tu dois mentir
ce que j'ai des fois des menteurs qui
oublient de mentir
et je les détecte c'est là où je suis
fort
Baptiste tiens-toi prêt
est-ce que tu dis la vérité
OK
j'ai entendu des portes grincées dans le
public
en même temps il a eu un délai
relativement court c'est intéressant je
retiens cette intonation ok pour
l'instant je serai plutôt comme ça
Aurore réponse selon le rôle que tu as
choisi est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
choisi le même rôle Baptiste et toi
non ok
c'est intéressant parce qu'elle a
longuement hésité
comme ça alors que Baptiste était plus
affirmé plus assuré moi je vais dire un
truc comme ça ok je demandais tous les
deux s'il vous plaît quand je vous dirai
à trois de tendre le bras vers l'avant
avec soit le pouce en l'air si vous
étiez en train de dire la vérité soit le
pouce en bas si vous étiez en train de
mentir à trois vous allez faire ça 1 2 3
ne bougez pas gardez les pouces comme
ceci
[Applaudissements]
pour moi tu es en train de dire la
vérité tu sais j'ai dit est-ce que vous
avez choisi le même rôle tu m'as dit non
effectivement vous avez pas choisi le
même rôle tu mentais donc
mais tu as oublié de mentir
vous n'avez pas choisi le même rôle tu
aurais dû dire oui je détecte même les
menteurs qui oublient de mentir
merci beaucoup je voulais te voir
je vous remercie d'apprécier cette
performance
car malgré tout on a l'impression que je
me suis trompé et en fait non c'est
parce qu'elle a oublié de mentir donc
j'ai inverse toutes les réponses
forcément que je pense et je trouve
quand même
pour ce test de mensonger de vérité je
vais donc maintenant vous tester pour
voir si vous êtes capable de détecter le
mensonge et si oui combien de fois on va
le faire avec trois personnes vous allez
essayer de le faire sur ces trois
personnes et compter de votre côté de
manière individuelle si vous avez réussi
une fois deux fois ou trois fois
attention des fois des gens qui mentent
oublier de mentir
trois personnes qui veulent bien se
prêter au jeu s'il vous plaît allez-y
lever la main trois personnes qui
veulent monter sur scène montent sur
scène je t'en prie ton prénom c'est
Aurore
je ne connais pas cette personne donc je
ne peux pas dire le prénom mais monde
sur scène s'il te plaît une dernière
personne s'il vous plaît ton prénom
Magali vient et la personne derrière
Magalie qui est en train de se faufiler
ton prénom c'est
Béatrice Aurore
Béatrice et Nathalie Magali je n'entends
vraiment pas quand vous me parlez
apparemment Magali ok c'est parfait
toutes les trois vous avez déjà été au
cinéma dans votre vie
c'est ça le mentalisme
je vais vous demander d'imaginer que
vous allez de nouveau au cinéma et que
vous alliez voir un film pas n'importe
quel film j'ai pris avec moi des petites
cartes de collection c'est un jeu de
société qui s'appelle action dans lequel
alors je vais enlever les règles
d'ailleurs dans lequel il y a plein
plein de films ça c'est les règles du
jeu au lance on s'en fout il y a plein
de films avec l'affiche d'un côté et de
l'autre côté le titre du film est
d'autres films que ça n'est pas je vous
en confiais plusieurs et on fera faire
le test de vérité de mensonges avec ces
films là vous avez donc un large choix
on va faire plusieurs niveaux de
difficultés avec Aurore ce sera le
niveau 1 le plus facile
avec Béatrice ce sera le niveau 2 un peu
plus dur et avec Magali le niveau 3
encore plus dur puisqu'elle vient déjà
de changer de prénom juste en marchant
niveau 1 je te donne quelques cartes
voilà pas le plus gros paquet niveau 2
je t'en donne un petit peu plus et
niveau 3 je te donne quasiment toute la
fin du paquet je m'en garder une juste
pour faire l'exemple ok une partie des
personnes de ce public doutent de moi et
se disent ah mais il sait dans quel
ordre elle sont rangées les cartes donc
allez-y mélanger les cartes s'il vous
plaît que vous avez reçu voilà vous les
mélanger dans l'ordre que vous voulez ok
c'est très bien une partie du public se
dit actuellement ouais mais comme il a
donné des paquets il sait quelle carte
il a donné à qui en attendant alors vous
allez faire comme quand vous étiez petit
ou petit du moins à l'école quand vous
aviez des cartes à collectionner vous
allez faire des échanges tu prends des
cartes à toi tu lui donnes à qui tu veux
tu en prends tu en donne mélanger un
petit peu ces paquets comme ça entre
vous allez y faites-le je compte jusqu'à
5 à 5 ce sera terminé 5 4 3 non j'avais
dit l'inverse en fait 1 2 3 4 5 c'est là
où tu vois que c'est un spectacle que je
veux pas la première fois tu vois c'est
vous avez donc maintenant des paquets
qui ont été mélangés brassés les uns
entre les autres vous allez former un
seul paquet que vous tenez comme ceci
devant vous chaque carte est composée de
derrière du titre du film il écrit en
haut en verre et de l'affiche
correspondante de l'autre côté donc vous
allez choisir un film et ce film vous
allez le mettre devant vous ce qu'on
appelle à la phase du paquet parce que
si vous le mettez juste tout seul et
bien nous on n'aura pas de mal à savoir
quel film c'est parce qu'il y a la fiche
de ce côté est-ce que c'est à peu près
clair ce que je viens de vous dire oui
donc choisissez un film pas forcément
votre préféré quelque chose qui vous
inspire et vous le mettez de ce côté-là
de votre paquet c'est ce côté là que
vous pouvez le lire vous l'avez parfait
je vais demander maintenant d'imaginer
que vous êtes dans la queue du cinéma
donc on fait dans l'ordre Aurore vous
êtes tué on peut se tutoyer Aurore tu es
la première de la file donc tu te mets
juste ici un tout petit peu derrière moi
mais ici
derrière il y aura le niveau 2 donc la
deuxième personne Béatrice et encore
derrière
Magali en niveau 3
à la fin pas de danse ou moi je suis un
petit peu louvreur qui vais vous placer
dans la salle on entend le bras la
machine n'a pas encore les gens qui
parlent l'ambiance du cinéma c'est parti
je vais te demander à toi qui fait le
niveau 1 Aurore de nous dire quand je te
donnerai le GO 3 noms de films
le nom de ton film et deux autres films
de ta carte qui ne sont en l'occurrence
pas ton film evidemment tu mets le nom
de ton film ou tu veux en premier en
deuxième ou en troisième on voit souvent
des vidéos où il faut savoir quel est le
mensonge parmi trois affirmations là
c'est l'inverse c'est plus dur quand
même il faut trouver quelle est la
vérité parmi ces trois affirmations
soyez chaud je vous rappelle que je
cherche mon repreneur ou ma repreneuse
en mentalisme
je donnerai tous les comptes de la
chaîne Youtube tout avec même
occasion de le donner
non c'est le mien Aurore les consignes
étaient-elles claires ok donc tu vas me
dire trois titres de films deux qui sont
sur la carte mais qui ne sont pas ton
film et celui qui est tout en haut qui
est en film que tu placeras en premier
en deuxième ou en 3e c'est quand tu veux
nous t'écoutons
coup de foudre à Notting Hill
Dirty Dancing
Gladiator et gladiateur
qui veut estimer qui veut proposer quel
est le film de vérité
quel est ton prénom Katia d'après toi
c'est lequel le deuxième je ne pense pas
non levez la main ce qui pense que c'est
le troisième et ceux qui pensent que ces
coups de Nothing Hill ah c'est à peu
près à égalité
moi je pense à
99,99% que nous sommes sur coup de
foudre à Notting Hills c'est correct et
bien c'est en salle 2 tu peux t'asseoir
merci beaucoup ah oui merci c'est gentil
je te laisse tout en cadeau
attention
retenez ceux qui avaient bon vous
marquez un point ce qui avait pas bon
des ventes
niveau intermédiaire maintenant avec
Béatrice Béatrice on va faire exactement
la même chose tu as bien compris les
consignes mais on va le faire avec 5
films et tu vas placer ta vérité au
milieu de ces 5 tout public à faire non
c'est un livre deux c'est intermédiaire
alors c'est quand tu veux nous
t'écoutons pense à placer ton film quand
même à un moment donné parmi ces cinq
c'est parti
l'arme fatale
Blade Runner
Casablanca
Titanic
et les tontons flingueurs ok est-ce que
j'ai une estimation quelqu'un qui veut
se chauffer
c'est quoi selon toi
moi je suis chaud avec toi je pense que
tu es une bonne mentaliste on est bien
sorti tannique ouais c'est en salle une
cela sera soit merci oui
je crois qu'il y en avait plus qui avait
Titanic ok pas mal elle l'a mis en avant
dernier vous avez vu pour pas l'oublier
c'était un peu prévisible aussi comme
mensonge on est d'accord dernière
personne Magalie tu es le niveau 3 le
niveau expert attention c'est pas simple
tu vas nous en dire 7 ou 8 on va même
pas les compter tu en diras autant que
tu veux mais place le tien à un moment
ou pas
tu fais
tu sais ça c'était une impro je n'avais
pas prévu de le faire je savais pas que
ça allait vous faire cet impactant oh
elle fait ce qu'elle veut un petit peu
bah je me dis c'est le niveau hard c'est
le plus dur ok pensez à bien noter si
vous aviez eu une bonne réponse de
bonnes réponses ou zéro
Magalie c'est quand tu veux nous
t'écoutons
les affranchis
grand Torino
the artistes
le Roi Lion
la momie
comme tu veux mais a priori on sort avec
lui
ou pas d'ailleurs ok vous avez c'est
plus compliqué là
parce que quelqu'un de chauffer
selon toi
ok j'ai des vrais mentalistes pour moi
c'est le Roi Lion aussi c'est bien le
Roi Lion oui
tu peux te rasseoir merci beaucoup c'est
en salle 5
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y a
pas tellement de hasard ceux qui ose
prendre la parole c'est qu'ils ont
vraiment perçu quelque chose vous êtes
sensible à ça vous êtes vraiment à
l'écoute et en plus d'autant plus simple
que vous voyez les variations de stress
sur quelqu'un qui est sur scène devant
300 personnes ça serait un petit peu qui
en plus vous avez aucun biais cognitive
vous n'avez pas d'enjeux personnel
vis-à-vis de ce mensonge ou de cette
vérité comment tu as su toi pour le Roi
Lion
par ses yeux parce que les yeux ont fait
Hakuna non je ne sais pas je demande
c'est possible lever la main les
personnes qui avaient zéro bonne réponse
pas c'est pas si nombreux je trouve ok
levez la main les personnes qui avaient
une bonne réponse
deux bonnes réponses 3 bonnes réponses
trois bonnes réponses vous avez vu c'est
plus rare que 1 et 2 c'est tout à fait
normal je vais mettre un tester si vous
êtes des bons émetteurs et des bonnes
émettrices relevez la main les personnes
qui avaient eu deux ou trois bonnes
réponses s'il vous plaît ok est-ce que
tu veux bien venir sur scène s'il te
plaît toi oui toi que je viens de
montrer du doigt absolument est-ce que
tu veux bien monter sur scène oui
mademoiselle oui et attends je vais
est-ce que tu veux bien monter sur scène
oui toi oui oui parce que tu étais en
train de faire ça c'était très stylé
ça va être un peu plus compliqué d'être
émetteur que d'être récepteur je vais
avoir besoin de votre pleine
concentration donc je vais vous mettre à
l'aise en vous donnant des chaises venez
vous placer s'il vous plaît alors
attends regarde je vais mettre cette
chaise ici quel est ton prénom ah tu
peux t'asseoir dessus je mette cette
chaise là tu peux t'asseoir dessus s'il
te plaît
et je vais mettre cette chaise ici voilà
tu peux t'asseoir dessus s'il te plaît
ok c'est parfait
oui je pense qu'on vous voit bien toutes
les trois je vais être un peu solennel
mais je vais vous dire ce qu'il ne va
pas se passer il va pas y avoir
d'hypnose il va pas y avoir de choses
bizarres et pourtant j'ai parlé
solennellement parce que je vais avoir
besoin de votre pleine concentration on
va faire de l'extraction de données
pures du cerveau si vous voulez bien
jouer le rôle démétriste en gros si ça
marche pas c'est de votre faute c'est ça
que j'essaie de dire
toujours c'est prévoir une part de
sortie de chaos je demandais donc à
toutes les trois s'il vous plaît de
rester uniquement sur ma voix de couper
les autres sens pour pas être
déconcentré d'oublier le public et pour
ça ça va être très simple vous allez
fermer les yeux tout le long de
l'expérience rassurez-vous fermez les
yeux ne se passera rien de bizarre quand
vous allez les rouvrir on sera pas un
genre tous partis dans une autre salle
en vrai ce sera un bon gag j'aimerais
bien le faire mais on n'a pas le temps
pour ça déjà on avait déjà commencé à se
lever ouais on fait ça non vous restez
ici donc fermez les yeux oublier mes
blagues oubliez le public et rester
uniquement concentré sur ma voix et sur
tout ce qui va se passer à partir de
maintenant s'il vous plaît
OK
la personne que je viens de toucher tu
es la spectatrice numéro une je te
demandais à partir de maintenant d'avoir
le visage impassible de rester bien
concentré uniquement sur ma voix
je te demandais d'imaginer un chien
c'est une pensée imposée pour toi parce
que tu vas être le support de penser des
autres personnes n'écoute même plus que
je vais dire par la suite reste
uniquement concentré sur ce chien c'est
le support de la pensée mentale des
autres personnes merci beaucoup et on va
continuer avec les autres personnes
la personne que je viens de toucher tu
es le spectatrice numéro 2 je vais te
demander de penser un prénom pour ce
chien
pas n'importe quel prénom ça doit être
le prénom de quelqu'un que tu connais ou
que tu as connu avec qui tu as eu un
lien positif
ou pas
en tout cas tu as un parc le type de
relation que ce soit amicale familial ou
autre cette personne doit exister
concentre-toi bien sur ce prénom s'il te
plaît
et à partir de maintenant tu n'écoutes
plus que je dis tu restes uniquement sur
ce prénom et tu le répètes dans ta tête
comme si tu l'entendais limite comme si
tu voulais le crier
la personne que je viens de toucher
tu es la spectatrice numéro 3 je vais te
demander quelque chose de compliqué tu
vas imaginer le tatouage présent dans
l'oreille de ce chien c'est pas une puce
électronique c'est écrit il est composé
de deux lettres et de deux chiffres
c'est de l'aide peuvent vouloir dire
quelque chose pour toi ou pas c'est de
chiffres peuvent avoir une signification
pour toi ou pas mais c'est deux lettres
et deux chiffres genre AA1 tu imagines
c'est de l'être essaie de chiffres tu te
concentres dessus et tu essayes de les
écrire mentalement comme si tu les
écrivais sur un tableau noir
concentre-toi dessus et uniquement
dessus ouvrez les yeux maintenant s'il
vous plaît
ne réagissez à rien et ne dites rien
restez dans votre concentration et dans
votre pensée
je vais vous demander à toutes les trois
de vous lever
je vais essayer maintenant de capter
toutes ces pensées qu'on a depuis tout à
l'heure
évidemment pour la première personne
c'est facile pour le prénom c'est plus
compliqué mais je suis très parasité par
toi depuis tout à l'heure
c'est quoi ton prénom
je les sens
c'est terrible
parasité de ouf
que dehors
c'est quoi le prénom de ta meilleure
amie en France
quand tu étais petit tu avais pas une
amie plus forte que les autres
je vais dire je vais révéler les pensées
qui a dans votre tête si je révèle votre
pensée
de manière très sobre pour confirmer à
toute la salle que j'allais bien révélé
juste ben on va faire comme pour les
films vous allez vous asseoir à votre
place
spectatrice une ça il y a pas
d'ambiguïté c'était imposé tu penses à
un chien par contre le prénom de ce
chien c'est Agathe et le tatouage c'est
AZ 42 si j'ai bien révélé votre pensée
imposer ou le prénom ou le tatouage vous
demanderai de vous rasoir
merci beaucoup
je peux faire une parenthèse hors
spectacle c'est la première fois que je
fais un truc aussi violent j'ai le cœur
mon pote
je suis très content que ce soit bien
passé voilà c'est et merci beaucoup on
peut les appeler hier très fort toutes
les trois d'avoir bien joué le jeu
mentalement
évidemment
j'ai une très bonne mentaliste du côté
de Aurore qui a donné le prénom aussi
c'est intéressant et pour autant je
crois qu'on devrait tout reprendre à
zéro
pas tout le spectacle
alors évidemment je pense qu'on devrait
tout reprendre à zéro c'est-à-dire toute
la recherche du nouveau ou de la
nouvelle mentalité qui prendra ma place
si par malheur il m'arrive quelque chose
on fait rire je pense qu'en fait que
tout le monde a ses chances je pense
qu'on peut faire un test collectif on
annule tout ce qu'on vient de faire ça
c'était limite votre chauffe mental on
fait un test sur toute la salle en même
temps il a personne qui réussit ce test
devient le ou la nouvelle mentaliste
je suis chaud pour ça vous allez toutes
et tous vous lever toute la fin du
spectacle vous serez debout on va faire
un quiz géant
est-ce qu'il est roux non
c'est enveloppe contient quelque chose
de précieux pour moi je vais le confier
à quelqu'un dans le public quelqu'un a
un peu loin de la scène mais qui soit
dans le champ des caméras pour qu'on
soit sûr que cette enveloppe ne bouge
pas ensuite par la suite ce sera toi
tu restes comme ça 27 minutes
merci beaucoup tu es pas obligé de le
tenir aussi haut mais mais je veux que
ce soit éloigné de moi je pense pour moi
dans ma définition que le mentalisme
c'est une forme d'illusionnisme de
l'esprit accompagné de technique de
mémoire de calcul de détection de
mensonges d'analyses d'extraction de
données des metteurs de récepteurs et
aussi d'influence
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'un bon
mentaliste ou qu'une bonne mentaliste
sache résister à l'influence tout en
ayant de l'intuition on ne comprend rien
à ce que tu dis
j'ai pris avec moi une pièce qui est
noire d'un côté et rouge de l'autre vous
le voyez ça c'est du rouge
désolé pour les daltoniens
qui voit de daltoniens non c'est noir et
noir
je vais faire un pile ou face très
classique et vous voterez ont révélera
la couleur du pile ou face les personnes
qui ont raté ce vote s'assieront à la
fin il n'en restera qu'un aucune le ou
la mentaliste qui reprendra le relais de
la suite de toute mon œuvre le mec va
trop loin
si vous pensez que la face est rouge
vous prendrez un engagement physique et
déterminé et visible même aux caméras
vous mettrez la main sur la tête ça ça
veut dire je pense que c'est rouge si
vous pensez que c'est noir vous mettrez
la main ici sur la bouche comme ceci
sauf le noir
rouge noir mais comme ça on aura des
vraies différences et on verra
clairement les gens qui auront perdu ont
les verra ils seront obligés de
s'asseoir c'est très clair c'est super
oui ok
votez maintenant
si vous pensez que le premier coup va
être sur rouge la main sur la tête si
vous pensez que le premier coup va être
sur noir vous mettez la main comme ceci
sur la bouche allez-y tout le monde a
voté j'ai pas de personne qui ne votent
pas ok c'est parti
alors
rouge ou noir
la tranche
tu peux annoncer la couleur
c'est noir toutes les personnes qui
avaient noir vont rester debout les
rouges vous vous asseyez vous êtes
décevant les rouges
vous vous êtes fait influencer par la
couleur rouge qu'on demande une couleur
à quelqu'un la personne dit toujours
rouge tu vois c'est un marteau il est de
quelle couleur rouge
attention on va faire le deuxième coup
votez pendant que je lance en l'air s'il
vous plaît pendant que je lance en l'air
vous votez si vous pensez que ce sera
noir ou rouge
tout le monde a voté au fond aussi ok
est-ce que tu peux annoncer la couleur
noire les personnes qui ont voté rouge
asseyez-vous
ça s'assied de plus en plus le troisième
coup je vais le déterminer moi-même
si vous pensez que j'ai mis la pièce
dans ma main sur rouge faites ceci si
vous pensez que je l'ai remise sur noir
faites cela allez-y faites-le tout le
monde a voté c'est bon partout dans la
salle ok c'est bon toi tu penses que
c'est rouge c'est vrai
toi tu penses que c'est noir pourquoi
les trois coups de suite pour une fois
tous les rouges asseyez-vous s'il vous
plaît asseyez-vous asseyez-vous
asseyez-vous on continue allez-y voter
là on prend de du dynamisme à partir de
maintenant rouge noir rouge noir
c'est noir c'est noir encore mais là
c'est pas de ma faute il y avait du
rouge ok on va faire avec beaucoup de
personnels peut-être ça va casser la
série si vous dites chocolatine
vous parrirez sur noir si vous dites pas
au chocolat vous parierez sur rouge si
vous dites chocolatine vous faites ça si
vous dites pas en chocolat vous faites
ça OK
on verra enfin qui gagne parmi les pains
au chocolat et les chocolatines
attention c'est parti vous avez fait ou
pas
c'est bon tout le monde a voté au fond
aussi je ne te vois pas ah non mais tu
as perdu toi au fond pain au chocolat ou
chocolatine
aussi longtemps puisque j'ai jamais fait
ce numéro
allez-y votez et votez donc s'il vous
plaît par opposition
sur
du noir tu peux t'asseoir et tu peux
rester debout
moi je suis bluffé de me dire que ça
s'est repassé une deuxième fois
parce qu'en fait je vous mens sur un
truc depuis le départ le plus gros
secret des mentalistes était c'est pas
la mémoire c'est pas l'influence c'est
pas l'analyse en fait c'est parce que
moi j'ai déjà vécu tout ça une fois
en fait le courant secret que j'ai c'est
que je fais de la chronoportation
je voyage dans le temps
donc c'est à dire à chaque fois je fais
un spectacle je rate
tout je mémorise les réponses je reviens
dans le temps et je refais le spectacle
pour ça que j'ai hâte d'avoir 40 ans en
fait j'ai 20 ans
mais je fais tellement d'aller-retours
dans le temps et
je pensais tout avoir sur des rires
je vous révèle mon vrai secret en fait
c'est comme ça que que je fais moi
espèce de Time Turner qui me permet de
publique de peu de fois et du coup je
m'étais dit là c'est pas possible ça va
pas refaire toute la série de noir etc
on va pas et si
c'est bluffant
voilà
vous allez vous avez l'air déçu de ça
c'est quoi ton prénom pardon
que tu que tu resterais debout à la fin
est-ce que tu l'as t'étais déjà resté
debout à la fin dans le futur de que
enfin c'est ton présent maintenant mais
tu vois ce que je veux dire quoi
j'ai une preuve de ce que je dis
je vais vous demander de mettre tous
votre main droite comme ça sous votre
siège
et vous n'allez rien trouver
est-ce que ça
[Applaudissements]
de regarder sous son siège tu peux le
faire s'il te plaît Tess
sous ton siège oui qu'est-ce que tu as
tu as une enveloppe bien sûr il y a
marqué quoi dessus
il y a même un truc au-delà de bravo en
fait c'est parce que je vais vous dire
le plus grand mensonge c'est pas de
chercher le nouveau mentaliste c'est
d'oublier de vous dire que vous êtes
tous mentalistes vous êtes tous et
toutes mentalistes est-ce que je peux
récupérer cette enveloppe que tu as dans
les mains depuis le départ
non la grande enveloppe oui c'est pas
très clair pardon
personne n'y a touché personne n'a
changé tiens regarde je te laisse
l'enveloppe
vous êtes tous et toutes mentalistes
c'est ça la réalité j'ai pas besoin de
savoir qui est le meilleur ou la
meilleure puisque vous êtes déjà bon par
définition c'est pas c'est pas de la qui
c'est le mentalisme on fait ça
naturellement en fait la seule question
à la limite qui se pose et je veux
ouvrir ça dans quelques secondes bien
sûr mais la seule question à la limite
qui se pose c'est quel archétype de
mentaliste vous êtes ça ce serait
intéressant de le savoir vous pouvez le
savoir en venant voir mon vrai spectacle
qui s'appelle archétype alors retourner
dans toute la France en francophonie
aussi et qui aura une grosse date à
Paris et vous avez un lien dans la
description pour ça avec toutes les
villes venez voir le respecter avec
celui qui a demandé un an de préparation
et pas de jour
mais abonnez-vous
dans cette enveloppe où il y a marqué
bravo pour te féliciter d'avoir refait
comme dans le futur dont je revenais je
t'ai mis deux places pour voir le
spectacle archétype où tu veux
car oui mesdames et messieurs je savais
qu'à la fin il resterait debout un homme
ou une femme
mais que précisément cette personne
aurait un jean bleu avec des baskets
grises et des bandes rouges c'est bien
le cas test oui ok mais tout le monde ne
le voit pas alors que tout le monde va
pouvoir plus facilement constater que tu
as un pull noir avec une écriture verte
si tu peux tourner pour le faire voir à
tout le monde merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci le grand point virgule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai adoré ce processus de création en
48 heures pour faire un spectacle
derrière j'aimerais bien le refaire donc
ça dépendra aussi un petit peu de la
vidéo de ce qu'elle rendra et tout mais
même si on le fait qu'une fois j'aurais
adoré faire ça c'est très sympa à mort
immense je vous aime très fort à très
bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]